Hey guys, it's Logan Marmino,
and did you know this show
is actually based on real-life Josh?
-Oh, hey!
-Hey.
Do we have time
to walk around set and talk?
Yeah, let's do it.
So, this is where
the Dubin family home schools.
We can tell your desk because
look how serious it is
compared to the other ones.
Did you have this home school room?
No, we didn't have this home school room.
We did like home school,
like, in our bedroom.
I did it in my closet, under my clothes,
doing my school at my desk.
-And, hit!
-Woah!
How much of the series is "real" real?
I think every episode has a piece of my life
that's real, and it really--
-Did you memorize everybody's--
-I really memorized everyone's names.
I used to, like, I really got a copy
of the eighth-grade yearbook.
Yeah.
'Cause I was actually
going into high school.
I memorized everyone's name.
And just like that scene,
where you were walking down the hallway
saying "hi" to everyone.
It's like, I did exactly that.
Hey! Dave Conrad, Josh Dubin.
Good to meet you. Love that haircut.
So one thing I find
people always want to know
is how we found you.
And we found you
in a pretty cool way.
-So, I made a post on Instagram.
-And... yes.
"Hey, we're looking for an amputee
to portray a boy about 12 years old."
Yeah, some person tagged me
on the Instagram post,
and you guys contacted me.
It was so wild,
because you've never acted before.
Yeah, I've had no acting experience,
in school, in anything.
There's a lot of actors in Los Angeles,
but there's not that many people, like,
your age with one leg who wanna act.
Actually, there's basically none.
Because we would've found them easily.
-Yes.
-Right?
It was really important to us
to find someone who actually has one leg
to play a person with one leg.
Then we were so glad to find you.
We're gonna show you some of the Easter eggs
that are hidden around the set.
My brother, Luke, who works
with baby sea turtles, is represented.
There's like eight or ten
sea turtles all around here.
Sea turtle...
sea turtle...
another sea turtle.
This was my
great-great-grandfather's chair.
Literally, like, my grandfather was rocked
in this exact rocking chair.
-Which is pretty wild.
-That is cool.
My parents just shipped it
across the country,
and now here it is on our set.
I used it when you all were babies,
and I would rock you all.
-It didn't feel small to you?
-No.
So these are all photos
of you in real life
-and the other actors that play...
-And all the other actors, yes.
-That's Romy and her actual brothers.
-Yeah.
But it looks like the family.
-Yeah, totally.
-That's why it worked.
-Do you know who drew that drawing?
-Who?
-Me!
-You did?
Yeah, I was like six or seven.
-Ah, that's pretty cool.
-Yeah.
Do we wanna go see the middle school now?
-Yeah, let's show the middle school.
-Let's go see the middle school.
We just walked out the house,
which is like ten feet,
and now we're already at the school.
So this is the foyer of the school.
A lot of big scenes happen
right in this room.
I'm so excited.
In my real life,
I did way too many activities.
In the show, we needed to figure out,
like, how can we show
Josh doing so many things?
And so we constructed this board.
What do we have on some of these things?
-Josh Sundquist.
-Oh, my real name!
Did you sign that?
-No, I did not.
-That's not my handwriting.
So we have Soccer Club, which I did.
Chess Club, Writer's Club,
Hockey Club, Cheer Club, Robot Club.
What were some clubs that you did,
or hobbies and sports?
Actually, I wrestled.
-Did I ever tell you that?
-Oh, no.
Yeah, I was on the varsity wrestling team
my first year of school.
I was terrible, but that was kind of how
we got the idea of the soccer episode.
It was kinda like my experience
as being on the wrestling team,
and are people going to go easy on me...
-Oh, okay.
-or not when they wrestle with me.
We wanted Josh to play soccer,
'cause I played--
And like second-guessed all of his life,
like getting on teams...
-Exactly, it's like people go
-and if he was really good--
easy on you, right.
What if all of my coaches have lied to me
and pretended that I was better than I am
because my mom made them.
How can I know how good I am at soccer?
When I was your age, I never saw someone
who looked like me on screen.
-Do you feel that way?
-Oh, yeah.
-Right? You've never seen that.
-Never.
And so to be able
to do a show like this...
And it's not,
"Oh, that's the kid with the leg."
-It's, "Oh, he's like me."
-Yes.
And they can see,
on television, the normal life
-of a middle-schooler with a prosthetic.
-Yes, totally.
That lightning is pretty sweet, dude.
Yeah, I love it.
It makes you look like a superhero.
Tell us about how you rehearse lines,
'cause I think this is so cool.
-With Peyton and Trinity?
-Yeah.
So, every night we rehearse lines,
go to sleep, wake up,
-and then they're all in our heads.
-Yeah.
We have it down to a science.
Have you and Peyton and Trinity
all become friends in real life?
Oh, definitely, yeah.
This has been really fun,
walking around the set,
finding the Easter eggs together
and talking about it.
But you have to go to a costume fitting.
-For the Halloween episode.
-Right.
-Gotta do it.
-All right.
Let's head out.
And cut. Great, got it.